thanks to curiosity stream for keeping
legal eagle in the air
i wish i had enough poison for the whole
pack of you
i would gladly give my life to watch you
all
swallow it i haven't seen that in court
but
generally that's not a great strategy
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer today we are covering the trial
of tyrion
from game of thrones like a lot of you
out there i am waiting
for the series finale but in the
meantime let's take a look back at one
of the
more famous repercussions of the purple
wedding
which is the trial of tyrion lannister
who
is framed for the murder of king joffrey
he's joking it's been a long time since
i've seen this so i'll be looking at it
with fresh
eyes but it'll be interesting to see how
realistic the trial scene
is compared to american modern
jurisprudence
as always leave your comments in the
form of an objection which i will either
sustain or overrule and stick around
until the end of the video
where i give game of thrones a grade for
legal realism
so without further ado let's dig in to
the trial of tyrion lannister
so here tyrion is being held in
captivity by the equivalent of the
police in
king's landing to recap king joffrey was
killed on his wedding day by some sort
of gruesome
poison and because of many of the
statements that tyrion made
to and about the king he is being
accused of actually
killing king joffrey which of course is
not in fact true
nonetheless he's being held in captivity
and is being accused of the crime
of regicide
all right the sort of game of thrones
equivalent of the perp walk
being walked into court
so this is a pretty unusual court
all of the people in the audience
generally called the gallery
almost always you have it being
perpendicular to
the actual place where the judge sits
here you have these long rows
going toward uh where the judge is going
to sit
it doesn't make a whole lot of sense as
a courtroom
obviously this is a great hall where
usually official business is conducted
but this doesn't make a whole lot of
sense
as a courtroom
generally speaking the accused don't
have to wear handcuffs when they're in
court
unless there is some known reason why
they have to be
uh restrained like they are known to
have
outbursts in quarter they jump across
council table and try and attack the
judge or the prosecutor
which has been known to happen but
otherwise for
obvious reasons you don't want to poison
the mind of the jury and see this person
as some sort of animal that has to be
chained up you want them to get a fair
hearing
so generally criminal defendants are not
locked up when they're in court
you would generally rise when the judge
arrives as well
i tommen of the house baratheon
first of my name king of the andals and
the first men
and lord of the seven kingdoms do hereby
recuse myself
from this trial tywin of the house
lannister
hand of the king protector of the realm
will sit as judge
in my stead so in the u.s you have a
constitutional right to a jury trial and
that jury must be made up of your peers
now
query in uh the sort of royal
house who would be the the peers
that would sit in judgment over a
nobleman like tyrion lannister
but you can also see that it is a clear
conflict of interest for one
of the three members of the panel or
jury that's going to decide your fate
to be a member of your own house here
you can imagine prejudice going both
ways there could be prejudice because
his father may want him to face
execution because of how much he loved
joffrey his
grandchild or you could imagine that he
could get leniency because he's a member
of the same family
tyrion of the house lannister stand
accused by the queen region to register
did you kill king joffrey
no did your wife the lady at sansa
not that i know of that's a fair
response he may not know whether his
wife
uh committed homicide or not you would
have to ask her so that would be
speculation for him to talk about
whether his wife killed
king joffrey how would you say he died
then
choked on his pigeon pie
so you would blame the bakers or the
pigeons just leave me out of it
i should note here that there are
already several problems from an
american law perspective number one if
this was in america
tyrion would be given the right against
self-incrimination under the fifth
amendment
which would allow him to not have to
testify against himself
in a criminal proceeding and already the
adjudicator has asked him
several questions that could be
incriminating towards
his defense and he would have the right
not to take the stand and not to have to
answer those questions but i don't get
the sense that
tyrion could have avoided those
questions if he wanted to
additionally tyrion would have a sixth
amendment right to an attorney being
present throughout this
entire ordeal because we don't expect
members of the public to be able to
defend themselves
in the court of law without the help of
an advocate like a lawyer
and here he has no attorney to act as an
intermediary
and you know he makes these statements
that are somewhat inflammatory and could
get him into trouble
the crown may call its first witness
once we got king joffrey safely away
from the mob the imp
rounded on him he slapped the king
across her face
and called him a vicious idiot and a
fool
it wasn't the first time the imp
threatened joffrey right here in this
throne room
he marched up those steps and called our
king a halfwit
compared his grace to the mad king and
suggested he'd meet the same fate
when i spoke in the king's defense he
threatened to have me
killed okay so you might assume that
these statements by tyrion
qualify as hearsay and therefore can't
be used
against tyrion in a court of law however
it's important to know that hearsay is
an out-of-court statement used for the
truth of the matter asserted they are
trying to establish that he actually
said these things and had a motive
to kill king joffrey so that is sort of
the truth of the statement at issue that
he thought the king was a vicious idiot
and a fool
so the question is can those statements
come in well
one of the exceptions to the hearsay
rule is generally the
admission by a party opponent or a party
admission exception to the hearsay rule
and under that rule you are allowed to
use hearsay statements where the
statement is
ostensibly made by a party to the
litigation or a party in this case
to the criminal proceeding and is
adverse to that party
and here they are using a statement of
tyrion who is a party to the litigation
he is the defendant
and it is adverse to his interest so
that statement is allowed to come in
generally the admission by a party
exception exists
because you can cross-examine the
declarant because they're a party to
the proceedings the big problem at least
historically
with hearsay is that it's an
out-of-court statement where you could
not cross-examine the declarant
but where the declarant is available you
are allowed to
bring in their out-of-court statements
through other witnesses
so in this particular case i think the
party admission
exception would apply and they would be
able to use tyrion's statements
against him in this proceeding oh why
don't you tell them what joffrey was
doing
finding a loaded crossbow at sansa stock
while you tore out her clothes and beat
her silence
that would probably be another
constitutional violation
in the united states tyrion has a right
to confront his
accusers and although he's probably not
allowed to do it during the direct
examination of the witness
eventually he would have the right to
cross-examine the person who was making
these statements especially when that
person
is relaying statements that tyrion
supposedly made out of court
so for him to be shut down entirely and
not be able to face his accusers and the
witnesses against him
would be a clear u.s constitutional
violation the confrontation clause to
the sixth amendment states that in all
criminal prosecutions the accused shall
enjoy the right to be confronted with
the witnesses against
him and here tyrion does not have the
right to confront the witnesses against
him and that would be a clear
constitutional violation
in this criminal trial this was found on
the body of
dauntless hollard the king's fool he was
last
seen spiriting sansa stark the wife of
the accused
away from the feast she wore
this necklace the day of the wedding
residue of the most rare and
terrible poison was found inside
was this one of the poisons stolen from
your store it was
the strangler poison
few in the seven kingdoms possess
and used to strike down the most noble
child the gods ever
put on this good earth yes king joffrey
what a good guy
such a shame that he perished in his
youth of course this is completely
improper character evidence
which is prejudicial against the accused
in this particular case but that is why
character evidence should not be used in
a criminal proceeding putting aside the
problems with the grand maester's expert
opinion here
in any criminal proceeding you have to
show what's called the chain of custody
of any particular piece of evidence
because the police will gather the
evidence and then you need to show
what happens to that evidence from every
step from being
gathered to being stored to being
produced in court
because all kinds of things can go wrong
especially when
you're dealing with dna evidence or
fingerprint evidence
and here the grand maester has
apparently just
picked up this random bracelet he then
stuffed it into his
shirt pocket or the sleeve of his shirt
and
just withdrew it at the trial itself
if i was a criminal defendant i would
really want to know
what happened and who possessed this
necklace or this bracelet
throughout the entire course of its
existence so that i could show
that it hadn't been tampered with if the
grand maester for example had an axe to
grind
against the defendant which he clearly
does here he could have taken the
bracelet and
added a drop of the poison that he is
accused of
using against uh joffrey the the king
here so
there's all kinds of reasons that in
modern jurisprudence you have to show
chain of custody and if i was able to
cross-examine this grand maester i think
i could really do
a world of damage showing his number one
bias and number two
that the chain of custody of effectively
the murder weapon is
really questionable at best do you
remember the precise nature of this
threat
i'm afraid i do my lord he said perhaps
you should speak more softly to me then
monsters are dangerous and just now
kings are dying like flies
and he said this to you at a meeting of
the small council
yes after we received word of robb
stark's death
he didn't seem gladdened by the news
perhaps his marriage to sansa stark had
made him more
sympathetic to the northern cause
well the latter portion of that
testimony is clearly speculation he's
speculating about
the frame of mind that tyrion had when
he received the news of rob stark's
death
the prior statements of tyrion at the
small council meeting again probably
come in
under the party admission exception to
the hearsay rule
father may i ask the witness one
question
one finally tyrion gets to confront one
of his accusers
jeez this is clearly a sixth amendment
violation and on top of it no judge in
the world
would ever limit a criminal defendant
facing
life imprisonment or execution to one
single question on cross-examination
this is an abomination of a criminal
trial at least as it
accords with the u.s modern standards of
jurisprudence
this is uh it's not it's not good to be
a criminal defendant in
15th century england or the equivalent
in in westeros
i did not kill joffrey but i
wish that i had watching your vicious
bastard die
gave me more relief than a thousand lime
[ __ ]
i wish i was the monster you think i am
i wish i had enough poison for the whole
pack of you
i would gladly give my life to watch you
all swallow it i haven't seen that in
court but
generally that's not a great strategy
not a great defense strategy to
insult the entire gallery and the entire
jury at the same time and
suggest that although you didn't kill
the victim you wish you had
i will not give my life
for joffrey's murder and i know i'll get
no justice here
so i will let the gods decide my fate
i demand a trial by combat
i assume you'd have to make some sort of
motion with the court
and you can't just request a trial by
combat when the
uh when the trial is not going
particularly well for you that being
said trial by combat is a real thing
that actually
existed in the 15th century in england
but it also existed well
into the 20th century in many places and
in fact some of the last
instances of trial by combat existed in
the 1960s
in france so it is not crazy for a
criminal defendant to request
trial by combat probably not a great
move by
tyrion because i think generally
speaking real life
trial by combat required the actual
accused to be the one doing the combat
but trial by combat was never an option
in the united states
so not realistic from a u.s perspective
[Music]
okay that was the trial of tyrion
lannister from season four of game of
thrones
now it's time to give this episode a
grade for legal realism
on the one hand you have evidence that
is certainly probative of someone
actually committing regicide and killing
the king through poison
you have some hearsay statements that
are likely to come in
under the exception to the hearsay rule
so that evidence probably would have
been
able to be used in this particular trial
on the other hand you have
tons of constitutional violations
including the
violation of the right against
self-incrimination the violation of
being able to confront your accused
and the violation of having an attorney
present during a criminal proceeding
all in all tyrion did not get a fair
trial and the deck was stacked against
him in a way that hopefully does not
exist
in modern u.s law so i'm giving the
trial of tyrion lannister
a d-minus for accuracy this episode
should be killed by poison
preferably the strangler i found it
surprisingly beautiful
in a brutal horribly uncomfortable sort
of way
did you know that much of what happens
in game of thrones is actually based on
real life events
especially the war of the roses in
plantagenet england one of the best
documentary series i've ever seen is the
real war of thrones on curiosity stream
it's an amazing series that explains all
the details that happened in real life
that gave rise to a lot of what actually
happened in game of thrones
for example how the lannisters are
basically identical to the real-life
lancasters and how the starks are
effectively the real-life
yorks it's an amazing series with
incredible production values so if it
seems like a lot of game of thrones
feels like real historical events
that's because it actually is if you
want some clues about how game of
thrones is going to end
your best bet is curiosity stream legal
eagles will get a free account for 31
days by clicking the link below or using
the promo code legaleagle
using the promo code really helps out
the channel so click on the link below
and get curiosity stream for free
and get your game of thrones fix while
you're waiting for the next episode do
you agree
leave your objections in the comments
and check out my other real lawyer
reactions over here
where i'll see you in court